so
the 10 past yeah it's 10 past so okay
hello everybody and welcome to
the uh i think is it is it seventh
high data meetup of uh yes of
2021 and so for
the ones that are not
so familiar with pi data uh we're
thinking to show some some slides so
that you get familiar
and hopefully if you get familiar you
come to the following meetups as well
so
pi data is an
international let's say educational
program
that provides a forum for for the
international community of users and
developers of data analysis tools
and it focuses on mainly
sharing ideas and learning from each
other
and
it's a it's a global network
it has a lot of chapters in a lot of
cities around the world
and
the network promotes a discussion of
best practices new approaches emerging
technologies for a variety of fields
ranging from data management to
data visualization
it aims to be an accessible and
community driven conference
with
talks of any level of
of expertise let's say
so from novice to advanced
it's organized by by a us and non-profit
organization it's called nam focus
uh that
it
continuously sponsors a lot of open
source
tools
you can see
the tools here i'm sure if you are a
data scientist or a software engineer
you most probably have used
at least one of them for example numpy
and pandas and
and
scikit-learn for machine learning are
also projects sponsored by uh by
non-focus
and and
so in santa cruz we are the only chapter
that that exists in cyprus so they were
the cyber structure and
it's organized by volunteers so i and
nick are both volunteers at the chapter
we organize monthly meetups and we are a
community of almost 700 members
so
at the moment so we are
we are one of the biggest communities
that is related to data science
and we hope to become more members and
also attract more people to the to the
talks
uh there are some upcoming events from
the
there are some upcoming events from the
um
from the global pi data
network
so
each year
usually there is a conference organized
by
by some of the chapters
but due to covet restrictions since last
year
the conferences kind of unified into one
and they they are offering this global
conference
it's going to take place on at the end
of october and uh so the program is not
out yet i think but they are going to be
very very interesting talks on data
science and
software engineering and so on
and with that
you're always welcome to say hi you can
find us at twitter here or at our meetup
website here
and currently
i and nick are the organizers you can
find us at our twitter handles there
if you have any ideas for talks please
please say come and say hi and
you can present at one of the of the
future meetups
and with that
let's go to costas
hello and thank you very much for the
invitation to
give a look
uh here i'm going to
present
let's see if it works did
just i want to go
can everybody see my
[Music]
pdf screen
like the first slide
awesome
okay
so i'm kostas i'm
a data scientist at nodes and links
and
the topic of the talk is applying
network science along with other
mathematical tools
but
network science is one of the
the major fields that we
that we apply
so
let me say a bit about the company um we
are a vc packed uk based company and the
tech hub is in cyprus
and um the idea what we do is
we provide business intelligence
solutions
to
customers that manage
the so-called mega projects so large
complex projects i'm going
to give examples um shortly
um
so one second
i'm having some trouble moving through
the slides okay it seems to work so
i'm going to give a brief introduction
into these complex projects and then
move on to what is the project schedule
the type of data that we're dealing with
and um the type of tools
as i mentioned network science mainly
and then
um
give us examples certain applications
the idea is
i wanted to keep the talk not too
technical but rather give more of an
overview of
this type of data science and this type
of data
so the modern economy
relies quite a bit on
very large projects so some examples
from the uk france and singapore
are shown here the high speed to the
rail running i think from the north to
south of the uk
um grandparent express the a14 motorway
in the uk
sanji and heathrow airports
thames died way is another very big
project in london
so
infrastructure projects definitely
concern a big part of the
of economic activity
nowadays and they're very hard to manage
because
they are quite long term some of these
projects might take 10 years might span
20 years
um people come and go throughout the
that span and the amount of information
all the amount of organization like
coordination that needs to happen
between several different contractors
is enormous
um there are many
challenges i think even just
googling any kind of project management
stream
will
probably give rise to certain news about
projects failing or
not finishing on time not finishing on
on budget
um one sec i'm going to
turn my
the light of my room here
on because it
became increasingly harder for me
to
to read um
to read my notes
so as i say the three main uh
items the three main aspects of the
project that
managers are focusing on
one is finishing on schedule
the other is finishing on budget
third thing is quality
and
there is a long
history of as i say
either failure or
things just not finishing on time or
at the expected quality
there are differences between different
uh sectors of the economy
and
also
certain differences
geographically around the world but as
you can see from these
produce controls
fact sheet
there is a large percentage of
unsuccessful projects at least in one of
the respects that i that i mentioned
that i mentioned before
now
the idea of project controls is very
this concept is very central to what
we're doing at nodes and links because
when you have a mega project to deal
with
um
there is a lot of decision making that
goes on
and nowadays there's a lot of data so
um the collection of that data the
management the analysis and the decision
making
that is led to is in general
called project controls in the project
management
field in the industry
and
the main things that
the project manager would be looking to
be enabled to do through project
controls is manage the project
effectively
inform decision making drug progress and
be able to coordinate effectively
nodes and links provide solutions to
facilitate and improve
this procedure
so far
the indus standard
depends
it still depends i guess on technologies
that were developed back in the 50s and
60s
mainly by the u.s military the critical
path method is probably the most famous
tool of these and pert program
evaluation review technique is
essentially
a
stochastic variant
of this so
in this model there is a randomness
introduced
the same technologies just with
increasingly new
software um
has appeared in many many types many
products
the
most famous of which are p6 by oracle
primavera p6 and microsoft project so
most of the customers would be using
one of these
two pieces of software
to first of all collect
the data which is a large process in
itself
and then to a secondary degree perform
some
analysis on them some computations
in order to
provide some estimates make their
decisions
um so so far this is the this is the
state of the art in the industry
now
the idea behind nodes and links is to
try and
bring this field to of project controls
to the digital to the digital age so
essentially
um we're providing a cloud-based
platform
that aims at improving project
performance aims at reducing the risk
for for the planners and the people that
are managing the project um it's a
modern platform there are many different
tools and screens in it um here you're
seeing actually
an image of the software as usb
a while ago um
the various graphs um there are most
more advanced types of visualizations
based on network science
there are
different types of analysis like
critical path and project progress which
are traditional
but are also
scheduled taking or
identifying the most critical paths to
any selected activity for instance
important milestones where
quite often
um
the the profit of the revenue
of these projects depends on so
essentially the customer would
basically be looking to
get certain milestones satisfied before
proceeding the next payments
so there is a range of different uh
screens and different types of analysis
in the in the product
moving on
the type of data
and
explaining a bit about what the project
schedule consists of
it is organized in terms of work
breakdown structures these are the
this is the most fundamental unit of
organization
and uh beyond that
there is further organization into what
are called terminal elements and mainly
activities so
um activities are essentially
pieces of work that need to be
implemented
in order to
progress with the project and produce a
certain deliverable
as an example here i have the
application of oil paint when painting
the canvas
there are six different types the main
ones are
what are the so-called tasks or resource
dependent tasks
but also i mentioned milestones so
milestones do not really have
a duration per se they're more there
to
to satisfy certain
progress and the other two types are
less common first of all and also
a bit different in the nature the main
focus is on task dependent resource
dependent activities in order um in
terms of the items that need to be
delivered
and make the project move on
now the idea of why introduce network
science into this type of data
is essentially due to dependencies
all these activities in a project so um
follow certain
logic there are constraints
there are
preceding tasks that need to occur
before another task can can start for
instance
so
completion initiation
of different activities is dependent on
these
logical dependencies that are set by the
planners at the beginning of the project
and here we have four different types so
the most common one finnish start means
that the prerequisite task needs to have
finished
before a succeeding task can start but
there are other
other types a bit less common sometimes
but they'll actually used in practice
and
and then another important element of a
schedule are resources which are either
people labor
or it could be materials or it could be
equipment or plant
and
a data set of project schedule consists
of
several tables that essentially provide
information about all these
items that i mentioned
they're actually
around 20 tables they're probably
they're more concepts than
i would like to go into
in this talk but i'm just giving some of
the
fundamental
elements
these tables are usually
csv formats and they provide all the
information all the properties all the
attributes of its
of these elements so activities and
their attributes then
dependencies
will also have attributes
uh what way the breakdown structures
same thing same thing for resources and
there are always
in a schedule apart from the
relationships between the different
elements
there's also the element of a hierarchy
so for example
uh
wbs's
are also organized between them in
a similar fashion to to fold the
hierarchy
uh
in you know computers so
um a tree essentially in network uh
terminology it's a trick
and
the
root wbs the primary one is always the
entire project
and beyond that
managers are separating into
big chunks of work so electrical for
example would be different to design
would be different to piping
and and this is how the whole structure
of wbs is generated and there's a
similar structure for resources
and also
as a user as a planner the standard
software that i mentioned earlier which
are used to collect this type of data
also allow for user specified fields one
example is
called activity codes
so there are many organizational
structures essentially behind
this datasets
duncan watts is a
famous network scientist and has worked
in several interdisciplinary
pieces of works and i just wanted to
to code him here
because i think this this particular
statement of his about the advent of the
internet the modern technologies
and also how it will affect the economy
or society at large
it's put on
i think nowadays there are many
different
fields
rising and being able to combine them
being able to
combine academia and industry and
further research is
is a unique opportunity at least in the
sense of the amount of data that is
being collected nowadays
um
and nodes and links i think is is an
example of such a modern company trying
to
leverage essentially everything
that is going on and bring
revolutionizing solutions to a field
that has existed for a while like
project management
um let's move on to certain examples now
i'll start with some concepts in order
to show you
how network science can be used to
represent concepts uh
about a schedule
and um
and
yeah i guess give an idea about the
connection and
how these such models
can represent the type of data i was
just talking about
so the most fundamental
concept is that of an activity network
essentially the schedule that i
mentioned the collection of activities
connected to each other
um
by the directional connections uh
so-called dependencies the logical
dependencies
um is directed network unipath in the
sense there is only one type of of nodes
and um also unweighted in the sense that
these connections the links
are not
do not um are essentially
the same uniform
across the entire network tire project
in addition
there are no cycles
which would constitute a logical
error in the sense if task b depends on
task a
which also depends on task b that would
be let's say a two cycle
um
it is a logical inconsistency so
if the schedule has been
prepared in a
meticulous way um the resulting network
that represents the schedule that
represents this uh logical dependence
between activities um should be a dac
direct base cycle graph and there are
specific tools and
theory within network science developed
for this type
of grass
so as i say this is the most fundamental
representation of a schedule the
activity network
and not also that it is characterized by
hierarchical structure so no matter what
layout
we use to
visualize this type of data
this is a
sort of random layout and earlier in the
laptop screen where the product ids was
shown there was a polar layout
but
these types of networks can always be
laid out in a hierarchical
manner
this is an actual a real world example
so
reading
ingesting the data set
from a project which consisted of about
550 activities
and almost double the logical
dependencies
um
this is a
network visualization
of it you can see that there are three
separate components
on it and
one of these components the nodes
highlighted in red this would be
the nodes of the critical path
so this notion essentially that
what a planner and manager cares about
is for the project to be delivered on
time
and this
the horizontal let's say the imaginary
horizontal axis here moving from left to
right
is somewhat representative of an actual
timeline so at this point we have a
project deadline
and
a project ideally
we would not like it to be late now if
certain tasks certain activities get
laid for some reason
then
we can
quantify the amount of project delay
that
they will cause
and then
be able to identify the most critical
activities within a project so in the
sense of if something goes wrong with
these activities then there's a higher
chance that the project the entire
project will be delayed
now moving on to the wbs and the
folder hierarchy that i mentioned
earlier and i only saw the wbs here but
exactly the
similar
property holds for the resources
in a project we have another type of
graph
similar characteristics to the previous
one
in the sense that it's unipartite
directed and weighted
however
this is a tree structure
so this
root wbs at the top
signifies the entire project usually
and then beyond that there is
branching
and this sort of branching essentially
represents the organization chosen but
by the people that are running the
project
and
to make things clear this
network is essentially
a different network to the activity
network both of exist so we have the
activity network where
activities are linked to each other
all these activities are actually
classified under a certain wbs because
wbs is a more
fundamental organizational structure
and
it's wbs has its own
wbs hierarchy
and a similar thing as i say holds for
resources because activities are also
assigned
various resources
and usually
at least one of
our labor resources at least one of
some material resources and with labor
resources there many roles as well
so it is quite common that
single activity would have
even more many labor resources assigned
to it
but then the resources themselves are
again organized in some other
structure which is also a tree structure
um a different example is the activity
resource by pattern network so
essentially
perhaps
one would like to look at certain
critical activities that might delay the
project and how many resources
are assigned to them
how many different subcontractors are
assigned to them how many
um
what type of equipment needs to be on
site or what type of material
and this can also be represented within
a network
structure it is a bipartite graph now so
there are two types of nodes
in the visualization blue and red
signifies the different types
but this one is undirected
there is no directionality and also it
is not weighted
in this particular
example also the size
of the
of the blue notes that are sorry of the
red nodes that are resources
also denotes how many tasks how many
activities are assigned to them which
might be
interesting
definitely of course
i'm not seeing the
relational interdependence between
activities here i've seen this before
that is true that is true exactly so
because this is a different uh network
in order to be able to visualize all
these
independences we would have to
essentially
connect the structure to the activity
network that i mentioned before in a
multi-layer network a kind of function
so this specific network is a different
representation and focuses specifically
only on
connections between uh resources and
activities so resource assignment
essentially the idea is to
get a certain type of insight from such
a representation
exactly i think in order to
um if we aim and perhaps a more longer
aim
is to represent the entire schedule
um
in
as an exact uh precise and
as comprehensive as possible view
using networks then
we would connect these different graphs
and create a very large multi-layer
structure so you would have um at each
layer would be a network and then even
these networks would be
connected with each other
um
but
for now and and for for starters
even um these specific different
networks that focus on uh
one particular aspect of a project
schedule like this one resource
assignment can be actually useful
to
to the people that are working on it
because people
so our customers are interested usually
to solve the problem in practice the
the value offered by this is mainly the
the informed decision-making that they
can make essentially so even focusing on
specific aspects can can be very useful
in practice that's the
that is the idea
thanks questions
you're welcome
and for instance here i have yet another
type of network this one is actually
derived
using the
resource assignment bipartite network
that i just uh showed
but it is a resource interaction network
so it's resource resource again it is
unipartite the only types of nodes here
are resources
um
also undirected
but it is weighted and the way it is
derived is
by checking which resources are
connected via their
assignment to certain activities so if
two resources awake are both working on
a single activity
we would create a connection between the
two nodes
and these connections would be weighted
in the sense that if we
look at the same
pair of resources and they're also
working at activity b
so essentially they're working at both
activity a and activity b then we would
um make
the weight of that connection um two
instead of one so it is weighted and the
weight represents
how many activities um uh risk resources
are commonly working
and again
this is a different type of network so
it highlights different aspects of the
of the schedule and um
[Music]
in its own right it can be used to
extract some useful information it will
just be different questions that would
be asked so
for the activities that network that i
mentioned at the beginning
the resource assignment network that i
mentioned the previous slide the
bipartite one and the resource
interaction network that i mentioned
here
um
a planner would
ask different questions
to answer by its
structure here for example it might be
of interest
to see if we have observed maybe
[Music]
delays in certain activities or there
are certain critical activities that we
expect to possibly cause delays
which resources are working on them um
if there are issues found does this uh
relate to
communication between certain different
contractors um what about material or
equipment plans
so there are different
types of questions that can be asked
from
using each different structure
now
to give you also an idea of the
different microscope visualization but a
product like
igs can provide in comparison to all the
tools so gun charts
and the activity network that will be
generated by primavera p6 the most
commonly used software
well the textual position is is here
essentially here we have a network
visualization
um different components
of this network uh
seem to also correlate well with
different wbs's so
the names here
essentially wbs
names
so
visually at least
i think the difference is is not
in what network science can provide in
terms of
viewing
project schedules
now i thought
as i kind of introduced nodes and links
and then moved on to the type of data
and then moved on to
possible mathematical representations
that can be used to model this data
to extract useful information
and i thought as a next
as a next step it will be interesting to
see
different uh practical problems so
different applications of this
and again an example without going into
too much little about the mathematical
approach that can be used or that we're
already using
so one problem is delay propagation
um remember these finish start
relationships between activities so if
the predecessor
is delayed the end date
is not met and then um
the succeeding activities will have to
incur delays uh because of that so
there's this propagation of delays
essentially
and um
one way to look at it in terms of
network science is
uh via
shortest path detection algorithms
essentially
and um one can find
a specified number of shortest paths but
it's arbitrary actually okay
from
a dummy start node
placed at the beginning of the project
connected to all root activities
root activities are those without
predecessors but which have successors
and the same thing at the end again the
dummy activity
connected to all so-called leaves those
activities that do not have successors
only predecessors
and
through this augmented network structure
do a lot of uh basically computer paths
do a lot of path detection
um using traditional algorithms like the
extra for example or others if negative
weight is to be included
and um
it's one way of
finding critical activities critical
paths
um through network science and it is
different from what i understand uh
from standard software
now a different problem
is actually that of the latent agent
which is
something that has been
hypothesized
perhaps not given as much attention
by the original researchers that for
example formulated critical critical
path method
but um
the data seems to
to indicate to at least provide
indications for the existence of a
slightly
subtler but
similar concept in terms of delay so
contagion so
propagation is when
the predecessors are pushing succeeding
tasks further into the future
however
there's this other notion that there
might be some kind of um
epidemic spreading
let's say of delay and this may be
may have different um
causes
for instance if there is some
subcontractor working on a sequence
of tasks or
just a set of tasks a collection of
tasks within a project
um it could be that there is no
delay
shifts no pushing forward but it could
be that they there there is some
inefficiency going on or some other
reason
why delays uh
okay
so this is a different pro problem
mathematically because
in this case we would be looking at
epidemic spreading i wouldn't be looking
at paths
and calculate and float
between the activities by the way float
i i didn't introduce but it is a very
important concept it's the amount of
time
in between
connected activities so once the
predecessor finishes how much time do i
have before the success
needs to start
and
it is quite important because planners
use it to also account for
uncertainty and unexpected
events
but at the same time
ideally they would rather
optimize the entire process as much as
possible for revenue and profit purposes
in any case delay contagion is is
different
as a problem mathematically and the type
of network science that would be useful
here is looking at spreading algorithms
cascading failures etc
a third problem is that of
um
viewing the schedule microscopically and
at a higher level because
these schedules consist of
thousands tens of thousands of
activities often and
even more dependencies
uh very big work breakdown structural
hierarchies as well so there is
a large amount of organization
and
it well the question is is it perhaps
possible
to
understand
this whole organization from a different
lens
and for instance
applying community detection principles
to the to the networks that we that we
saw the activity network for example
and see if some different sort of
aggregation um
arises essentially
and so this is a different uh
completely different
type of problem it has to do more with
human beings being able to manage
the project
identify
critical aspects and also
[Music]
track the progress without needing to
tell
too much into into detail
and
finally i have
another practical problem and i thought
for this one
as a final step i might move a bit more
into the technical detail as well
this also involves
um
some stuff i would say statistical
mechanics or
again it's topic
pretty close to network science mean
field approximations have been used
for a while
in network science to
to produce analytical estimates and be
able to compare with
simulations
so but
yeah as i say i decided this one is a
topic that i've worked on personally and
i thought i might provide just a little
bit more detail
so
rework is another important concept it
is
it is so important because
it is one of the primary causes of costs
and schedules
and it concerns re-implementation of
activities
the reasons there's a variety of reasons
like omissions or errors or poor
communication failures
um
changing the
specs
problems with documentation coordination
so
um there's a variety of reasons at the
same time in terms of academic research
it's a topic that has not really been
addressed that much
and so
there are not
no known tools in order to deal with
what's the problem effectively modelling
and
try to extract information from the data
so what we did here is
we created the
so-called master equation the area is
as as i mentioned
we have the activity network so matrix a
here now stands for the adjacency matrix
of that network so essentially
predecessor successor
connections between activities
and
um and i have i have a schedule very
simple simplified network here activity
three depends on activity two and four
being completed and they each depend on
activity one
haven't been completed uh two and four
can't be
worked on in parallel
so for tasks
this type of project would have six
possible states
which are denoted in equation 2.3
and
the first
foundational state is nothing has
happened there are no completed
activities final state is everything has
been completed and we have all these uh
parcel states in between so in this case
there are six possible states
as the size of the project so the number
of activities
becomes larger
and depending on the link density so the
amount of dependencies and in some sense
the more the dependencies
between activities the harder it is
for a human being to deal with it so the
more
complicated it is for human being
um the this system of uh of states also
grows and it grows much faster actually
than uh it's not
equal to the size
of the
the project network
so here we have four tasks but six
states
now
looking at transition rates between
states so wkm denotes transition from
state k to state m
and
introducing some parameters in the model
for instance a certain completion rate
or a certain rework rate like going back
and re-implementing a task
and then
doing some a little bit of analytics
mainly using the log total probability
one can arrive at
um a master equation and this equation
describes
the temporal
evolution
of
pk which is essentially the probability
that our project is going to be a state
k at time t
naturally
as time increases we would like
the k
state to be the final one so in this
particular instance
s6
and
this equation can of course be solved
numerically but at the same time one can
look at what happens by setting the
derivative equal to zero so what happens
as t tends to infinity in the long term
and obviously in the long term it is
definite but from managers or planners
perspective
pk
where k is the sixth state in the
previous example should one
ideally and all other
pm
should tend to zero so all parcel states
so the incomplete state should have zero
probability
of uh for the project being uh occupying
them
essentially so there is um just using
this model this equation there's a
variety of analysis that can be done
and um
when and as they tend to infinity
doesn't say in that
limit
um one can also analyze
various values for the reward grade so
if we assume a certain completion rate
that could also be drawn
from
an empirical distribution based on data
so durations
of activities for example actual
durations um
one can examine the range of the
parameter in this model it's called r i
haven't shown here and this parameter
describes the rework rate
and then one can ask the question
what is the critical value of that
parameter of rework
that will make my project go from being
certain to finish to being completed to
start being
uncertain to have a higher probability
of it
remaining in a partially complete state
and um based on this idea essentially
this question can we examine what
happens with different values for the
river
crate what we did was
investigate
all different topologies
of a certain size so we did it for
i've got results for size 3 and size 4
here for size 3
and specifically directed acyclic
graphs the only four possible
configurations that are shown here
namely the star
the serial connectivity the inverted
star and the triangle
and um
i'm showing them here in hierarchical
visualization that's why this does not
look as a triangle the fourth one but
essentially based on the master equation
that i just showed
plus
the
parameter analysis the sensitivity
analysis that i mentioned how much
rework
is allowed before the project starts
being lesser than
to complete
we can uh we managed to actually
classify
all the different uh networks and say
that
if you have a star
the the score is going to be higher so
we can run this one in this sense the
star is more
robust to rework
in comparison to the other three
configurations
of course in this very simple setting it
makes sense because
you know here you have only one root
activity and then these two can be
performed in parallel
so it makes
some sense of course that is always how
much sense it makes is always dependent
on the parameters that we used
um
now when you move up
size though for instance let's go from
three nodes to four nodes
suddenly we have 24 different
configurations and obviously this number
keeps growing for size
five there are even more et cetera
and
starts becoming
less trivial as to which topology is
more robust more resistant more
resilient
to rework occurring
and note that this is a
context agnostic rather than a
context-specific um
view of the project because the question
we are asking is
not can we predict how much we work
we're going to have it's not um which
activities
are going to be more
prone to rework
these contacts these are
context-specific questions and um
other type of data
than the the type that i mentioned on
the type that we have at opposition
would be necessary to answer them but
with the data we have even simply with
the connectivity between activities the
logical dependencies
it is possible to ask which structure is
more
resilient
from this perspective and so again we
have uh actually ranked and also
classified this because
there are 24 different networks but
there are
at the same time only i think 10
different equivalent classes so
for example the serial
would be equivalent to all these because
they're
essentially serial connectivity graph
with some extra link
so i'll stop with the technicality here
i just wanted to show that
this
wealth of data of project data that we
have is amenable to various sorts of
mathematical analysis and um
as a company we're very interested in
pushing research further into
understanding projects further into
bringing new
solutions
in collaborating with universities and
also we're definitely looking for
intelligent data scientists that are
quite keen to tackle
this type of questions
so i think i will
stop here we're probably
close to the
time limit
and uh thank everyone very much for
for listening to me and it was a
pleasure to
to be invited at pi data
meetup
thank you costas that was uh that was
super a lot of information
um
i will open it up for questions and
people are of course free to stay or
leave
and ask questions
by a muting or in the chat that's up to
you i can see that
there is one question already feel free
to and you can ask
because um
i've been with
doing project management for almost 15
years with construction guys for almost
10 years
a lot of
different kinds of projects
different types of projects
so
and of late last three four years these
have become data rich as well
the
advantage of data has been
in india at least towards
controllability not in the sense of
project controls but
if you have enough data and you know how
to visualize them
you
probably can control your budgets better
and that's our experience
what uh i mean and uh i've shared my
linkedin profile happy to explore that
further
my big question for you today is
most data is lag data
um
i would like to see
ai
uh
uh
bring in innovative
approaches uh
one of the classic projects was the
hoover dam and
it was a 11-year project
which uh
harya crowe that was the nickname for
him crow was the project director he
finished it in eight years
it's it's just
unbelievable
for a construction project
to be ahead of schedule and
somewhere
uh the birdie in my head
says data science complexity
uh
could probably with ai could probably
come about doing such things so
sorry big question
uh open question
love to hear a response or maybe
definitely
no it's um thank you very much for the
question uh chad carr um
i
first of all
it's it's something that that we hear
often as you said the construction
projects been delayed or been
going
quite
high over budget
so it is it is actually very interesting
to hear about this example where it
finished the head of schedule i i also i
agree completely i think data science
can
create solutions that will help manage
these projects uh more effectively
and
we can already see it i think on a
variety of levels variety of aspects so
one
probably the simplest example that i
could that i could give is all these
data sets that we have one issue is that
they also contain errors sometimes or
um there needs to be some kind of
processing pre-processing sanitization
so when uh we started um
creating models and algorithms um for
nodes and links
this was one of the first things that we
had to look just for the sake of our own
like verification of the algorithms that
we're creating etc
and in the end
this created the product component
about schedule checking essentially
and um and you see immediately even
such a sim
relatively simply you know barely data
science it's it's the beginning right
it's one of the foundational steps like
uh clean the data set somehow but even
that uh had actually a lot of value
for
for clients because
it's much easier to to have something
automated essentially aggregate
all types of errors that have been
precisely defined and classified
and show them to you on a screen you
know right there in front of you rather
than have
many planners that do know the project
obviously you know better than
better than us but
having to to actually do a lot of um
work to
to look through compare different things
and
use the intuition it is one of these
tasks essentially that
you know a machine
is
essentially better at doing in order to
free the time of the human being to do
something more
creative and useful
so i think
if as i say if even
this
simple solutions automating solutions
can help then
actual data science that can perhaps
provide more insight about the
complexity
um provide more insight about how to
perhaps
you know plan
the whole uh schedule for instance
knowing um having some knowledge about
what constitutes resilience do we work
things like that i think in the long
term
it is
it is almost certain in my eyes that
data science will really really help
with projects
performance projects efficiency
improvement
my audio is going on and off so i
thought you weren't speaking and then i
heard this picture feel free to continue
your question if you want or you know
or otherwise andrea you have that
yeah i'll wait for andrea
okay thank you very much
my question may be naive or um
i mean it's just like a question i have
um
so
for example in some of our projects that
we have
here at uh
cypress institute one of our issues is
that sometimes people tend to
drop the projects
this is very common in in
phd like related projects so for example
joint doctorates and things like that my
question is that would it be possible
to predict behavior human behavior
given that we have sufficient data sets
from previous sociological studies in
order to predict whether or not this
project is visible or will it need an
extension
based on certain profiles so if we make
if we have people complete
questionnaires before hiring them giving
them an offer
and given that we have a big enough data
sets which i guess exists in some
capacity
well if we bypass the ethical issues
because i guess there are many ethical
issues on that
would we be able to integrate it
in such do you believe that it's
possible to in the future to integrate
it and maybe predict
not necessarily reject people but at
least make sure that the risks involved
are accounted for in a larger capacity
than we can that we were able to do now
without these complex models
i i think um
it's certainly possible
to integrate
with this sort of data
at the same time i guess the
predictability would really depend on
the
quality of data that has been gathered
already in sociological studies plus the
quality of the conclusions actually you
know the quality of the analysis and
that i would probably be
um a bit more skeptical
rather than this sort of data so this
sort of data
i guess in my eyes and i've seen in my
experience many different types like
i've worked with time series um with
this sort of thing worked with
positional data from
ocean floaters
and over my experience i
maybe depending on the field as well i i
tend to
kind of classify different type of data
and their reliability in my mind and so
if we're talking about something here
like ago floaters and and oceans
that type of data is more physical type
of data
so i have it in my mind as more reliable
i would trust any conclusions more
then moving on to this kind of data like
project data where i've seen
um the various classes of errors that
can happen as well with the sanitization
the pre-processing that i was talking
about earlier
um
i have in my mind as less reliable but
still
i
knowing the sources of error and having
a good sort of picture a good idea
helps a lot
and then moving on to
social data or economic data other types
of fields more social sciences which
have
i've done to
to a lesser extent at least
professionally
i have it in my mind as a bit
harder type
a bit less reliable data at least for
now right because in the future
everything improves and things are
getting better but
um
so to answer your question i think the
how successful this predictability
could become
really depends a lot more
on on that
on those fields and those type of
studies and those type of data in my
mind the
practical aspect of integration of
creating forecasting models for this
purpose i think we are probably already
there
it is possible to do these sorts of
integrations and combine
i would just be as i said like skeptical
they would be interested in modeling
um
[Music]
how to call them assays but
i would be more skeptical about the
conclusions to be honest at least right
now
okay thank you very much uh and thank
you for the talk it was really
interesting
thank you
if there any other questions of course
feel free to ask
because
i know your
notes and links your attempting
risk analysis
but for me
looking at the schema
i feel
strategic risks are harder
to
capture and
especially in lag data like this we've
been debating uh
ai in a number of forums in india and
the company has to work with
they have huge
essentially
they have invested a lot of money into
making sure
a lot of detail is captured you
mentioned equipment data resource data
and so on
um
my my big concern
is the
what
i have seen
is that when you do risk analysis during
implementation
there isn't so much to benefit from
the most of the benefits come
during the proposals i'm more talking
from a contractor point of view and
that's where my experience also is
so the contractor view and the proposal
uh
perspective is important for
uh i i think nobody is
trying to capture
or bring in ai for proposal management
and
i think maybe as nodes and links gets
further
you would be able to capture risks
across a portfolio of projects
construction projects
not just within the project
uh would
does that sound uh
i mean my comment does it sound
okay to you definitely
it definitely does um it's very
interesting actually that that you
mentioned this because um
[Music]
it's also good for us
data scientists to
try and uh get you know this kind of
intuition that we're missing that people
with actual experience in projects do
have
and to see
how
you know what are the more important
facets of a project
and
in terms of being able to essentially
leverage
historic data or
data aggregated across a number
of projects is
may yeah
something for the future maybe but at
the same time i think
with
a lot more interesting and with a larger
potential
in the end because what you're talking
about uh
essentially means maybe even tackling
larger
uh issues that the whole industry is
facing but they don't really know about
or that the
whole company might be facing but they
don't know
about so it's interesting it's certainly
where things are also going the funnels
and links are has been no minds
for the future and as we keep gathering
collecting more and more data
to
as you mentioned not just work on a
single schedule but try to extract
information from looking across many
different projects and schedules and
make statistical estimates as well and
and perhaps be able to identify more
systemic kind of issues rather than
issues concerning a single piece of work
a single project
so yeah definitely it's it's very
interesting to hear this perspective
thank you
thank you chakrabar am i pronouncing
your name correctly
perfect
thank you
okay
i just want to reiterate something that
christos wrote in the
in the chat which is that uh no gen
links is hiring i assume christos is
either the founder or a hiring manager
um
one of the two founders
if anyone is interested in the ceo
of the company
i guess it's worth knowing that their
job posting
any other questions
yeah just another small one
so
it's a small one i mean so
if i'm if if i understand correctly so
this this this this um let's say these
methodologies can be applied also if we
want to connect
only european level institutes correct
like if you have on-boarding of services
on a larger platform
like the open sign european science
cloud could this be applicable between
the various partners of a project
and an overall arching uh structure
but that encompasses all of these people
trying to
populate it with services let's say
i think certain elements um would be
obviously the way that the platform has
been
growing and the data science behind it
the way it's developing it's
to
kind of customize on project scheduled
data
but i think the mathematics the concepts
it can be equally applicable it's just a
matter of
using different
data sets let's say a different template
or something but i think the maths a lot
of the the informational part
can be can be applied to
coordinate different types of
projects different
people
and use it for other purposes
essentially so i think
the math
or a lot of the math discussed in here
can certainly have applications to
to other
similar but not exactly the same you
know not exactly the same kind of
concepts
okay perfect thank you very much
i was also wondering
since
a lot of this graph
a lot of the math behind what you were
saying has to do with
networks and
they're not necessarily related with the
same machine learning but i was also
thinking that
there are this
graph neural network which are very
popular nowadays
uh and whether there is any
um application where they they are
relevant
in uh
in in northern links essentially
definitely i'm pretty sure uh they're
very relevant so
i think
the general approach followed here
can be termed you know complex systems
or complex signs something like that but
or network science but
um
that is one stream like
complexity networks dynamics these sort
of uh fields
it's definitely the approach that i've
been mainly discussing today but there
are
other approaches that can have i think a
lot of a lot of use and we're also
thinking about it you know for the
future for what we're going to do in the
future machine learning definitely
encapsulates classes of techniques that
can be very useful also you know the
type of data that we have
we're talking about you know as i
mentioned 20 or more tables and each of
them different number of columns not all
numerical quiet a lot of them are
you know text essentially names and uh
those those sort of stuff so
it is amenable to
you know completely different types of
analysis like more machine learning
oriented and i'm pretty sure in the
future we are going to integrate
incorporate components from those
approaches to
to the product
switch are there any other questions
i'm happy to wait until everyone's
questions have been answered
another small one and really quick for
me that i was thinking was whether
of course these projects you described
customers are quite big projects and uh
for good reasons
of course uh it only makes sense to do
this analysis in bigger projects but is
that is there some sort of metric limit
or
um
way to know i mean this is a business
question essentially is there a way to
know whether
something like um
there's a project
a project has a size
that can benefit from nodes and links
and if it's below the size essentially
these techniques are not very applicable
very good question a very good question
it's interesting to think about for me
as well um
you know in in principle
you can apply
this stuff
you know to the project of any size
but obviously if it is too small maybe
a lot of these concepts do not really
apply and you don't
you know not really care about them
i am i'm not sure if there is a way to
somehow
figure out the limit but i think
i can give you some
actual
an idea of actual numbers so many of the
projects that uh we receive can be from
500 to
100 000 nodes essentially
and it could be anything in between
depending on size
more commonly though i guess
the
if they're up to 10 000 nodes they're
more common if they're above 10
000 they probably you know
really large they would really benefit
um below if we're talking
hundreds like i think even for a 500
node project or even a 200 node
um
probably some of these concepts apply
well and there can be benefit just out
of some data sets that i've seen
um
if we're talking about i've never seen
any project you know below like 200
nodes so if we're talking
below that
i'm not sure i think some more some
research would need to happen
to see and also it's not just research i
think it's also the field expert
perspective as well like um because
with any model
it's impossible to have you know a super
accurate model that acts as a perfect
representation and for project data that
i mentioned it would be something like a
huge multi-uh multi-layer network where
many
network science algorithms and the ai
like machine learning algorithms are
running on that and you do you know huge
simulations
but then
one is asking whether that has any use
whereas with smaller models that are
definitely not you know representative
fully of reality but where you can
extract some useful insight from
practical questions
you know that that is generally
more useful so i think
to answer the question we would have to
it would have to happen some extra
research
from data scientists plus collaborators
from
project planning like planners to see
what questions are they interested in if
they have to deal with a
50 node
network like a 50 a project of 50
activities
and then you know yeah if you allow me
can i paint a sexy picture definitely
because i was finishing here anyway i
wasn't going to have anything
so next question towards the smaller end
of the spectrum
so when i look at ai which is
doing confidence modeling
when you have smaller
projects
and when you
bring in the confidence level of the
team
that's when
ai really
becomes beneficial and also
the context matters quite a bit
when you look at
especially indian projects or projects
in africa for example
um
the dynamics are different
and
so there's a challenge there
and i feel that even
you know 20 activity
projects
even if it's only for 15 days
there is a lot to be done uh for example
there are
some really super fast projects when you
build
solar farms
and um as you can imagine
chinese
teams have built about
10 gigawatt farms
in two and a half months
the network structure for that is very
very simple
uh
but but uh i don't think anybody else is
anywhere else in the world is capable of
capturing that speed
yeah so that's where
i i mean that's the sexy part of where
nodes and links in the future can get to
so i thought i'll add that
it is super interesting to get your
perspective on this chakra it's really
interesting
um
to hear and yeah going back to the
question of uh of size it's
it's a very i think uh
it's very interesting question to look
at
sure i hope that helps me
is there anything else any other
questions
nick your response would have been
helpful whether
hearing the sexy versions of
what note then links in the future could
do
for small projects uh does that help uh
help you in your
thinking
uh what do you mean so i don't work for
notes and links yeah i don't know i know
but uh the question
our comments came from your questions so
here i think the conversation has moved
to
what ai or what data
data science can do for projects
pushing those boundaries is what your
your
i was mainly asking to be honest i
didn't have a particular application in
mind i mean i work in nlp in particular
and there are some
graph neural networks that i'm aware of
so i was wondering whether they applying
this case and similarly for the small
project i was thinking only that
you know like a lot of projects in here
in cyprus infrastructure-wise are quite
small for example this is something that
can apply there but
just out of curiosity
okay
thank you
is there any other questions feel free
to ask otherwise
we're gonna call it a day
we're going to
release this uh
in our youtube playlist so
and
so you can have it and watch it
afterwards we plan to do another meet up
in a month
and we actually also plan to have it uh
as a physical event so if you're in
cyprus and koji in particular
we're probably gonna do it
live but we're also going to have a zoom
link as
we have here for people that
are not
either any kosher insiders
so we look forward to seeing you in
the next one
thank you very much
well thank you thank you for the
invitation it was very nice and uh the
questions so the conversation was really
nice as well nice to meet everybody
and see you in the next one
perfect bye
bye